[Music]
making a big fashion statement last
night Dakota Johnson in a low-cut
Valentino gown at the premiere of Fifty
Shades don't oh my god that was one sexy
dress but the movie gets even hotter
so Carly Steele found out how the stars
get ready for those steamy scenes we got
something about that don't we can yeah
we do you guys have a pregame ritual
before these scenes like mints he does
push-ups and I just like lay there and
drink whiskey Dakota and Jamie Dornan
had a bit of a competition with who had
the most risque humor on the set
intrigued he thinks he's better at
everything with me and he's really not
he was misinformed yes you brought it
with the dirty jokes I grew up with four
brothers you can have I will win sixty
three-year-old Kim Basinger plays
Christian Grey's ex-lover
but the notoriously shy stars skip doing
interviews last night Jamie was just a
three-year-old boy growing up in
Northern Ireland when her sexy film nine
and a half weeks came out I was always
that what is this not enough week's
thing that I wasn't allowed to watch and
then I was sitting there subsequently
when I was became a young adult and I
was like all right okay I know why I
wasn't allowed to water I still can't
believe I'm in a movie with her it's
very cool very cool
Kim looks amazing I used to have such a
big crush on her still do
you